understanding of how bad this fake deity
and the Zionists use them in many ways
and I believe what happened in Gaza is a
massive sacrifice to this fake deity bad
the innocent people is a must sacrifice
the children men and children they did
it purposefully
everything you own from your clothes to
your car to your wife or your husband is
going to forget you and move on and be
replaced the moment you die that's why
Allah says
you are busy with the worldly affairs
until you visit the graves. Brothers and
sisters, masid Norway, the one that we
built is looking to another masid around
the area of Norway. Subhan Allah. Where
there's so many Muslims that do not have
somewhere to pray. This masid is only
$500,000. And any donation that you give
will go towards your because when you
enter that grave, nobody's going to
remember you except Allah subhanaa tala.
So make it count, brothers and sisters,
and donate towards this message,
inshallah, a new project that's only
$500,000. And believe me, if every
single one of us give £1, £10, £100,
£1,000, that's going to be something you
will never regret on your Makyama and
everything that you lose is going to
perish and go. But your deeds on your
Makyama are not. Donate to the link,
inshallah. Let's get to the video.
Brothers and sisters and dear friends,
hope you guys are well, inshallah. I was
just here with a good friend of ours.
Alhamdulillah. And I was saying the
first time I'm filming a video and just
feel a little bit off. I don't know what
it is. It might be that the topic that
we're discussing today I film a lot of
videos as you guys know but I'll be
honest with you this one feels a little
bit off um things are not going a bit
smooth but anyways we don't know why but
alhamdulillah morning and evenar uh well
the morning inshallah the evening will
be coming soon in which is very very
important to protect from evil eye magic
and all that kind of harms I actually I
won't be alive if I was not doing that
so it's very very important especially
for public figures to do that let's get
straight into the video in brothers and
sisters this is of uh Iran a protest
that happened and for some odd reason
they had the god uh well a face fake
deity bal which is mentioned in the
Quran safhat uh but they put Epstein's
picture there they put this uh image of
this it's like a cow/ like weird looking
creature with a the star of David that's
ascribed to the Zionist uh and we're
going to come to who is it why did Bar
is fall into uh worship in it and this
goes way before to the time of Babylon
but here's a video from Iran inshallah
and the protest of uh them symbolically
Burning the C I don't
Okay. So what we can see subhan Allah in
a nutshell is Iran chose to do this
which I find I don't know why but
obviously uh they are obviously accusing
the Zionist Israeli regime uh of
worshiping Bal. Now what how does Bal
play a role in this? as you know the
Epstein files and his little island,
they had like a little temple where they
would worship or sacrifice satanic uh
stuff that was going on and which we
know it was already going in that
island. But this goes back to a long
time of uh time of maybe time of
Babylon. Allah talked about in the Quran
as well where you know they mentioned
the god Bal um and they would do satanic
stuff from sacrificing children to you
know what was going on in the island and
not only that Epstein actually had a
bank account named Bal. Uh so you can
see this is connected to that and it's
very interesting because it proves the
Quran's what Quran says to be true
because how is Allah subhanaa tala
talking about this connecting it to ban
is and we're not saying every single one
of them because there were the children
of Israel that obeyed Allah and Allah
mentions in the Quran many times when
Allah told them not to fish in the
Sabbath there were those that disobeyed
there were those that were silent that
Allah destroyed both of them and there
were those that abstained and said we
fear Allah so we can't put ban Israel
and the Jews into one category and that
all of them were disobedient. No, Allah
condemns the one that needs to be
condemned. Then Allah praises the one
that is to be praised. So now the video
I'm going to show you guys explains who
is Bal. Where does this come from? So go
to the uh verse in the Quran if we just
go to it. So Allah says, "And Elias uh
was indeed one of our messengers.
Remember when he said to his people,
will you not fear Allah? Do you call
upon the idol bal and abandon the best
of creators, Allah, your Lord and the
Lord of your forefathers?" But they
[clears throat] rejected him. So they
would certainly be brought for
punishment but not the chosen servants
of Allah. We blessed him with honorable
mention among other later generations.
Peace be upon Elas. Indeed this is how
we reward the good doers. Okay. So the
bal uh uh the god was connected to um uh
weather fertility and all this kind of
stuff. So they believe that sacrifice
into that. Now it's very interesting
because Allah subhana wa ta can give
them that thing. It's like anything that
Allah can give um it's there for the
people but what people do is go through
the means of the shin and whatever and
what Allah has given them the power to
do like with dal dal will have certain
powers that Allah gave him he's not
doing it at at by his independently of
himself and that's a fitna as a trial so
it's strange that instead of people
seeking the means from Allah subhanaa
tala by worship alone they go and cut
corners and at the detriment of entering
the hellfire when Allah subhanaa tala
could have given them more and Allah
mentions in the Quran So let's go to
this video inshallah where this
describes a video I saw on YouTube
channel describes who is bal inshallah
and their their connection subhan allah
uh to how some of the children of ban is
when they fell into shik. So let's go to
that video in
>> Baal isn't just an ancient [music] idol
and he's definitely not what modern
conspiracies claim. The Quran mentions
Baal by name and what it warns us about
is far more dangerous than [music] a
statue.
Some people think Baal is just a
forgotten pagan [music] god.
Others believe he's a secret symbol used
by powerful elites today.
But both sides are missing the real
story.
Bale was a real object of worship in the
ancient world and the Quran presents him
as a clear example of sherik placing
trust, fear or devotion in something
other than Allah.
In this video, we're going to separate
fact from fiction. [music] We'll trace
who Baal actually was in history. Why
Prophet Ilas confronted his worship. How
Baal later became a figure in a cult
texts. Why modern viral claims including
Epstein related ones fall apart under
evidence. And what Islam wants us to
understand about Baal today.
>> Okay. So what the scholars say so from
what we know is that any false deity
will be in the hellfire. Now some people
say okay but what about isam the
scholars say that anyone that is pleased
with the worship towards their self. We
know is alam rejects that in the Quran
and Allah said did you ask them to
worship you anymore. They said oh Allah
you know what's in my heart I do not
know I will never call them to such a
thing. So that is clear and one thing we
need to understand is sometimes uh what
people don't understand is like they
think false idol worshiping like
Satanism and Zionist using black magic
and sar and cabala and worshiping bal
etc to get powers or whatever for that
matter it's not like like it's not just
a satanic like this looks satanic like a
de like a cow with symbols etc it looks
satanic no the same can apply for
Christians who have Jesus as a holy
looking figure and you're doing the same
thing to Jesus you're worshiping a shik
you are ascribing worship worship and
giving credit to Jesus. Yes. Not that he
asked for it. So even if it's like a
holy looking figure or a demonic looking
figure, shik is shik one doesn't make it
more holy than it looks if it looks
angelic. Yes. If you go down the route
of saying we worship Moses or we as
Muslims come and say we worship the
prophet Muhammad peace be upon him. It
it doesn't it doesn't make it correct.
Shik is shik. But let's carry on in the
video.
>> To understand why Baal matters in Islam,
we first have to understand who Baal
actually was. Bale was not a fictional
character or a modern invention. He was
a real figure worshiped across the
ancient Levant, especially among the
Canaanites and Phoenicians more than
3,000 years ago.
The word Baal simply means lord or
master in ancient [music] Semitic
languages.
It wasn't originally a proper name. Over
time, it became a title used for a
specific deity known today as Baal
Hadad.
Bale Hadad was believed to control
storms, rain, fertility, and
agricultural success. In a world where
survival depended on rainfall and crops,
this made Baal extremely powerful in the
eyes of his worshippers.
People didn't worship Baal because they
were ignorant or foolish. And just to
mention another thing guys when it comes
to this issues it's not that bal or
whatever they invented in itself is a
figurel is behind all of this. So if
somebody jah in that time came and said
I you know this is a god deity I made
called bal yes and Allah will test them
yes and he come and said look you know
pray to it once and you'll see
happening. Yeah, it's it's it happens
with the princ of course, but it's not
that statue within itself or bal it's
behind the scenes that things happen in
the sense where it's a test from from
Allah to those people as well are they
going to have tawak that's why for
example in my traditions when you drink
Turkish coffee they turn it upside down
and look for fortune telling and there's
a saying in my culture that says do not
believe in it but don't go without it
and my mom used to be involved in this
and I told her about it I told abstain
from it because I said mom you might say
something that is not true but somebody
you might say and say oh you're going to
get married in two weeks and shin and
jin work in whatever how they work with
it with the Allah and they
[clears throat] make that happen and the
person will say ah see you said this and
it came to be true so do you see how
people can fall into the f and why we
should abstain from shik to the best of
our ability and have taw in Allah in of
our affairs
>> they worshiped [music] him because they
were afraid afraid of drought afraid of
hunger
afraid of losing control. And that fear
is exactly what made Baal worship
dangerous.
Because Baal wasn't just a belief. He
became a system of dependence, rituals,
sacrifices, [music]
and obedience to something other than
the one true creator.
And this is very vital. You know why,
guys? Because we worship and I say this
to a lot of people we worship Allah
because of who he is not because of what
he does for us only. Of course we
Allah's favors etc. Allah mention of we
worship Allah because of who he is.
Meaning if Allah created us cuz what
does it say here? Because of desperation
etc. What do people do? They turn to
fake deities. If you understood who
Allah is, even if your skin was being
ripped apart, unless it's for in force,
you would never worship any other
deities because you say, "I worship
Allah because of who he is, not because
of what he gives me, you know, gives me
good stuff. Okay, I worship him." He
doesn't give it. No, I don't likel. Why
did I fell into disbelief? Because he
worshiped Allah conditionally. He
thought he's going to be a specific m of
Allah. When Allah said bow down to Adam,
he said, "Whoa, I worshiped you for a
long time." Because of what? Because of
what you was the m that I had. The
moment you talk, it means what? He
genuinely and truly didn't worship Allah
cuz if he did, he would have bowed down
to Adam. He worshiped Allah
conditionally. Okay? And we worship
Allah because of who he is.
>> The Quran does not speak about Baal
indirectly or symbolically.
Baal is mentioned by name in surah a saf
in the story of prophet Ilas peace be
upon him.
Allah tells us that Ilas was sent to a
people who worshiped Baal even though
they knew who Allah was. Ilas called out
to them with a question that cuts to the
core of faith. Do you call upon Baal and
abandon the best of creators? Allah your
Lord and the Lord of your forefathers.
[music] This wasn't just a challenge to
a statue. It was a challenge to their
misplaced trust. According to classical
tapsier including Iben Kir, these people
did not deny Allah's existence. They
compromised their worship by relying on
Baal for provision, safety, and success.
That compromise is what Islam calls
shik.
Shik is not only bowing to idols. It is
assigning divine reliance, fear, hope,
or ultimate authority to anything other
than Allah. Prophet Ilas stood against
[music] an entire society built on that
compromise.
He was rejected, opposed, and isolated.
But a law honored him, and a law
condemned Baal. And that condemnation is
permanent.
Over centuries as Christianity and
demonology rose, the pagan Baal was
demonized
in the Ars Goedia part of lesser key of
Solomon 17th [music] century. Baal is
the first spirit listed a king ruling
the east appear.
>> Okay. So in a nutshell what I will say
is this as you can see it was demonized
satanic and what did they do? For
example, Christianity came and turned
that bad figure into they they deemed um
Isaam to be a holy person. Do you see
how it changes? Is the one that's behind
it? You can make it bal this etc. It
just changes. It comes in different
forms. And this is how you know if you
read
I think it'sl Yeah. Is that the the
tricks that Shayan does on the
Christians the Jews even some Muslims
etc which goes back to this not having
in Allah and as Muslims we fall for the
same thing. We want to get married it
does not work etc. Oh you know subhan
Allah maybe I should do something like
this or maybe should go to a pier. No,
Allah is testing you. And believe me,
I've been tested. I've been tested with
many, many stuff. But when you stay firm
to your dean, okay? And you put your in
Allah, Allah answers your duas in his
time, not your time. Not I want to. No,
no. Who are you to tell Allah when to
answer your duas? Who are you to know
what's good for you when it's going to
be answered? That's why you put your
trust in Allah. Have which is what? I
trust Allah. I've asked. There's no
doubt Allah is going to answer. Have
firm. Be sure.
And then you leave it to Allah's time.
Brother, this studio that we're in
today, you guys are looking and
thinking, I made dua for the studio 9
years ago. Nine nine years ago, not one
year ago. 9 years ago. Yeah. I said,
Allah started this charities
organization for a reason. We stuck by.
Alhamdulillah. Now we're here. Things
are falling into place just now. Yes.
I'm making dua for a marriage for years.
Yes. Allah's plan is the best plan. You
know why? Because every time you are
patient and have Allah, Allah answers it
in the best way possible and it is more
baraka for you. Anytime you go cut
corners, go to a pier, this person etc.
cut corners, Allah will destroy it and
Allah will put no barak in it. So have
that trust inah. And as you can see the
same thing is done when Mus Alam saved
them from he went to Allah subhana wa
ta'ala when he came back what were they
doing? Worshiping a yes there you go and
this is it. And you know what it is? is
sometimes an inferiority complex cuz
banan is surrounded by canonites etc
because they had a deity they said no we
want something physical cuz the god that
we worship we can't see him okay and the
prophetam told us the ones that worship
Allah without seeing him will enter
Jenna inshallah so let us be among those
who have Allah and hope you've got an
understanding of how bad this fake deity
and the zionist use them subhan allah um
in many ways and I believe what happened
in Gaza is a massive sacrifice to this
fake deity bad the innocent people is a
mass sacrifice Okay, the children, men,
women, children, they did it
purposefully and may Allah subhanaa tala
destroy them. Till next time,
everything you own from your clothes to
your car to your wife or your husband is
going to forget you and move on and be
replaced the moment you die. That's why
Allah says
you are busy with the worldly affairs
until you visit the graves. Brothers and
sisters, masid Norway, the one that we
built is looking to another masid around
the area of Norway. Subhan Allah. Where
there's so many Muslims that do not have
somewhere to pray. This masid is only
$500,000. And any donation that you give
will go towards your because when you
enter that grave, nobody's going to
remember you except Allah subhanaa tala.
So make it count brothers and sisters
and donate towards this message
inshallah a new project that's only
$500,000. And believe me, if every
single one of us give £1,10, £100,
£1,000, that's going to be something you
will never regret on your makayama. And
everything that you lose is going to
perish and go. But your deeds and your
makyama are not. Donate to the link
inshallah.